tiens couchois couche toi mais tu es
gens sur les épaules pour faire circuler
deux cents hommes respirent calmement a
alors est-ce bien ok c'est bon tu te
sens mieux la voilà c'était un fermier
non mais enfin j'ai aidé des types qui
faisait débat d'après en retrait du
crack ou d'autres eu besoin d'un fois
une fuite voit la mer vers le ciel c'est
ton point de fuite d'accord
la petite fille complètement folle
moi c'est pareil je vais très très mal
mais en 2000
mais tu as tout ans manon non c'est
différent là
sinon je connais bien je suis mal et bah
ouais ah ah non ce type que je connais
mais qu'est ce que vous faites là pas
pour soi bonsoir je suis un cousin
éloigné du témoin en fait d'accord vous
présente un ami c'est un ancien client
que j'ai défendue a way est accusé de
quoi ce type stupéfiants et d'ailleurs
je voulais vous remercier de m'avoir
sorti d'affaires c'est fini là je dis
plus haut n'a pas être à jamais la tête
d'un dealer de toute façon j'ai toujours
dit ça oui
fait des réponses courtes soient polis
mais pas les schleck la présidente ça
peut agacer
il faut que tu sois le jeune mec cool et
frais et comme tu n'as ni femme ni
enfant ce qui est un vrai problème pour
nous je ne le cache pas il faut vraiment
qu'on mise tout sur ton travail ont été
au chômage c'est vrai mais tu es un
chercheur au chômage ok il faut qu'ils
sentent que tu as une vie saine
équilibrée et à des responsabilités
professionnelles aussi que tu remplis
enfin moi je suis free précaires alors
il faut que tu saches aussi que je
démarre toujours par le dégoût coups
commencent à bari a dit l'avocat qui
préfèrent éviter la boulette moi je
fonce dedans premier dois-je affronte le
début les dents tout casser les six
chevaliers évidemment démarre à part ça
j'ai quand je m'habille 1,8 soit propre
mais pas trop chic faut pas qu'il est ce
une stratégie ça oui ça va être un non
ça va pas du tout j'ai hyper plein dis
toi une chose c'est que ta force c'est
ta beauté
non mais pour deux raisons la première
c'est qu'on peut pas réellement croire
qu'un beau mais vous avez tué la
deuxième c'est que statistiquement les
bobines puisque les mais c'est pareil
pour l'intelligence tu vois les jurés
ils sont toujours plus indulgent avec un
type intelligent qu'avec un débile parce
qu'ils s'identifient n'ont pas hésité
pas à sortir des mots comme un
visiblement ostensiblement tu bien ça
manifestement incontestablement est
assurément